welcome back to las vegas now unlv
hockey kicks off the road to the
american collegiate hockey association
d1 national championship tournament it's
kind of a mouthful and they're starting
with a big send-off party mike tomco
with unlv hockey is here to tell us how
fans can celebrate with them so congrats
skating rebels yeah i love that boys are
amazing boys are absolutely amazing
they're wonderful they're in practice
right now we're practicing right now at
city national that's our home court
the guys practice there we play our
games there in fact this friday and
saturday are the last games of the
season they're playing oregon ducks and
it's a home game right it's a home game
so this is your last chance to get there
down there tickets are ten bucks for
adults five dollars of kids
students and kids under for free
refreshments sell merch it's it's a lot
of fun i love it best hockey no one has
ever seen
it is they are they're wonderful
they're good kids they're 24 41 okay so
that's started our road off to head up
to nationals okay that was i was going
to ask you about the season how did the
season go leading up wonderful okay so i
mean their record of 24 401 has got to
be the best in the history of the school
wow for the team
they had invited to a championship over
the holidays in chicago that they took
the chicago classic they won it the
whole thing came home with a nice fat
trophy and now we're off to nationals
and we're trying to come back with
another big fat trophy oh yeah we're
coming back with a nice big fat trophy
for the skating rebels look good come
back and we'll get it we're going to do
it i have faith in him they're going to
do it that's beautiful and to celebrate
we are having a send-off party tell us
the details and how everybody can come
help you guys everybody can come to this
it's a send or party it's on monday
march 7th 6 to 8 p.m
it's going to be at the lifeguard arena
down in henderson cool it's 100 per
ticket now remember where we work
strictly on donations and sponsorships
this is benefiting the team so it's
benefiting the team for travel costs
equipment meals you know lodging stuff
like that it's all put together for that
and that but that's not the only
incentive that 100 is getting you no
that's getting you in the door and
you're getting a full buffet for two
hours an open bar beer and wine we're
gonna have uh auctions like a silent
auction with some amazing things we got
from the golden knights the silver
nights we're getting stuff from
hopefully the aviators
a lot of great stuff that we're going to
raffle up both there and online very
cool and let's talk about your fans
because you are inviting all your fans
you guys have a great team obviously
what is the atmosphere like at your
games it's insane it's pure insanity
it's pure insanity our media team has
thrown together a pregame video that is
very slim to what the golden knights did
okay so the fans get into it it's good
it's loud it's it's crazy it's it's real
hockey it's good hockey it's good it's a
professional hockey it's great hockey
you would never know that these are
college kids yeah you know these these
they play like pros they play like pros
and they're gonna win the championship
they're gonna win the national
championship in saint louis they leave
on wednesday morning again come down on
monday night it's a hundred dollars
ahead of lifeguard uh doors open at like
5 45 it's from 6 to 8 p.m check out the
gifts we'll have a couple of team
members there meet and greet with the
coaches
come have merch and then the the uh
gotta get the merch got to get the merch
go get the rebels emergency but the home
game though yes home game is 7 pm at
city national yeah friday night saturday
night against oregon tickets are 10
bucks
polk drop is at 705. okay
it's tickets i believe for friday are
almost sold out so come to the door and
first come first serve it's great we
work with the golden knights and food
and beverage it's
going to be good it's a vibe they're
going to win they're going to win
they're going to be oregon well we they
have our support here i support here i
want vegas now boys will be happy
exactly good luck boys